-Welcome back to
the show, buddy.
It's so good to see you,
and thanks for playing
that game with me.
-Oh, yeah. Anytime.
-I knew that you were levels --
You're levels above.
You were already
playing the game
probably before it even
came out there.
-Yeah, I'm like a --
Yeah, I like to plan ahead.
I'm like a criminal mastermind.
-Yeah, you really are, yeah.
-Yeah.
-I have a thousand things
I want to ask you about.
I know you probably can't tell
me much about "Stranger Things."
-Yeah.
-Season 4, right?
What can you say?
-Well, we --
What I can say is, like,
we just did literally 300 --
We just finished shooting,
and it was Day 300.
-What?
-Yeah. We shot for 300 days.
-Holy moly!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is it a longer --
-The audience claps.
None of the crew was clapping.
-They're exhausted.
-They were like,
"Alright, cool, guys.
Yeah, cool. Yeah, we'll leave."
No, but it's great.
-Wow!
-Yeah, it was a long --
-Those Duffer brothers, huh?
-Yeah. Like, I'm so glad they
still care, 'cause, you know,
if a show runs for that long,
the creators stop caring.
They cash in.
And they really still care.
-Yeah. You can tell.
It's quality stuff.
Last season was awesome.
-Yeah. Yeah, the show
is going to be --
It's going to be
really messed up this season.
-Well, I wanted to
test your poker face,
'cause I know we just
played "True Confessions."
So I will -- I'm gonna just say
four rumors about this season
and then I want to see your
reaction and see --
-Oh, yeah. Okay, cool.
-And we'll see if
it's real or not.
-Yeah, sure.
-Will we find out what happened
to Hopper this season?
Okay.
♪♪
How about Mike and Eleven?
Are they going to reunite?
-Oh...
[ Laughter ]
-"Oh" is the funniest answer.
Will we see Eleven
get her powers back?
-But...
-Yeah.
Who are the Creels
and what's their connection
to the Upside Down?
Okay. There you go right there.
That's it.
That's how you do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
♪♪
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
-Thank you for playing
along with that.
-Yeah.
-I want to talk about your music
for a little bit here.
-Yeah.
-This is your album cover.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love the art.
-Yeah.
-What is it?
Is this is an artist?
A famous artist?
-No, it's the drummer
in my band.
It's me and my friend
Malcolm Craig,
and Malcolm did the cover art.
He's an amazing artist.
-That's fantastic.
I love it.
-Yeah.
-The name of the album is
"Karaoke Alone."
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I have done that, yeah.
-Yeah. Oh, that's sad.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-Someone asked me that question?
They were like, "Have you ever
done karaoke alone?"
And I was like...
-Of course.
-..."No, no."
-Well, not really karaoke,
but you probably sang
in your bedroom or something.
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I mean,
like, karaoke bar alone.
Like, I just imagine you, like,
disheveled after a day of work,
by yourself in a karaoke --
-Glass of whiskey?
-Yeah, in your -- By yourself.
-Beer. Yeah, sing...
♪ All by myself ♪
I'm trying to think
if I ever have.
It sounds like something I might
have done just to, like --
I think I had to, like,
practice for some --
I had to do an
impression of something.
-And had to go, maybe, yeah.
-Well, in my apartment,
everyone can hear everything,
so I went to a karaoke place to
practice my impression
of Bruce Springsteen
or something.
-Yeah.
-Just so I can go like -- Yeah.
Because my neighbor will be
like, "Go to bed!"
-Yeah. Yeah.
-So I probably did
go to karaoke alone.
-A very New York neighbor
of yours.
-Yeah, exactly. Right?
Exactly, yeah.
But let's talk you about --
Because The Aubreys
is the name of your band.
-Yeah.
-Were you all ways called
The Aubreys?
No. You were in
a different band.
-Yeah, I was in
a different band before,
and then I formed this band.
And then it was going to be
called The Audreys,
and then there was another band
from Australia, I think,
called The Audreys.
And then I said,
"Wouldn't it be funny
if we just swapped the
'D' to a 'B'?"
And we started laughing.
And then we did.
-Dude, that's the way to do it.
-So -- Yeah.
-So The Aubreys
is the name of the group.
-Yeah.
-I love it.
-Great name.
-"Karaoke Alone."
Do we know
when it is coming out?
-Yeah, November 5th.
-Oh, wow!
-Yeah.
-Big month.
Yeah.
-You have a big month,
November, 'cause, dude,
you're relaunching, rebooting
the new "Ghostbusters."
-I am.
-Congrats on that.
-Thank you.
Yeah, it's actually kind of
almost, like, a direct sequel,
but it's, like, made --
I mean, obviously,
the original came out in '84.
And, yeah, Jason Reitman
is writing and directing it,
who's Ivan --
-His son.
-Yeah, it's his son.
And it's, like, a really amazing
kind of family affair.
-Your family moves
into this, like,
in the middle of some farm that
their dad -- her dad left her.
-Right, right.
-Her dad is Harold Ramis'
character.
-Correct.
-And you get to this
farm and you're hanging around,
playing and you go --
Is it under the garage?
-Yeah, yeah.
Mckenna Grace,
who's an incredible actor,
plays my little sister,
kind of starts to uncover
some spooky stuff.
-Yeah.
Then you find the Ecto-1, dude.
-Yeah, I find
the Ecto-1 in a garage.
-Dude, you get to drive
the Ecto-1?
-Yeah.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, it's so --
That's pretty cool.
-It is really cool.
-And you got to meet
the original cast?
-I did. Yeah. Yeah.
It was nuts.
-I mean, you can't --
Dan Aykroyd and Bill Murray --
you can't get better,
nicer people.
-No, that's what's crazy
is that they were, like --
It's like being
in the room with, like,
the Apostles or something.
Like, you don't, like -- It's --
[ Laughter ]
Like, I don't know
if that it makes sense,
but, like, it's weird.
It's like seeing,
like, you know,
Bill, like, you know,
leading the charge.
It's, like, really --
And I just called him Bill
like I know him really well.
-Yeah.
-You know, when Billy led
the charge on set,
it was so awesome.
When we were at Nobu together,
it was so cool.
-He does have a magnetic --
a magnetism.
So does Dan Aykroyd, as well.
-Yeah.
He makes everything he's
ever in better.
-Yeah, I agree.
Both of -- But you, too, bud.
-Oh, thank you.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
-Yeah.
-Here's Finn Wolfhard in
"Ghostbusters: Afterlife."
Take a look.
-Is that a...
-Free-floating metal muncher.
Definitely Class 5.
-Okay.
-Uh...what do we do?
-Let's get him.
-What?!
-I'm gonna get a photo first.
-Guys...
-Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
-[ Gasps ]
-It has a gunner's seat?
[ Creaking ]
-Go, go, go!
[ Tires squeal ]
-Yeah! Finn Wolfhard!
"Ghostbusters: Afterlife"
is in theaters November 19th.
Go check out his album by
The Aubreys, everybody.